thank you so much jc let's talk all
things beauty and brows as we head into
valentine's day weekend i'm introducing
you
to a local woman that can fill your
brows with love
sabrina welcome to las vegas now hi how
are you
good good it's good to see you good to
meet you virtually obviously you are
the owner of bina's beauty bar because
look at your hair look at your brows
look at your makeup
thank you i appreciate it of course so
what services do you offer
uh so i specialize in permanent makeup
so i do micro bleeding micro shading
combo brows and then i also do
a plasma pen treatment which is the skin
tightening treatment
micro channeling and then i do freckle
and beauty mark application as well
micro bleeding how does that yeah so
microblading
is done with a handheld tool and a blade
and then what we do is we insert pigment
manually
uh stroke by stroke so we create hair
like strokes onto the skin
um of course in between the brow hair so
it gives the illusion of a natural full
brow
that's awesome how long does it last
yeah so it usually lasts about
up to a year longer just depending on
the skin if you take a look
um this client did have some brow hair
but
obviously there's some sparse areas her
arch isn't
um really there as well as her tail so
what we do is we just
fluff the brows up and then fill them up
where it's needed so it'll still look
very natural but it'll be
um the way her brow should have looked
we'll even everything out and then
obviously we go based on the symmetry of
her face as well okay now let's talk
about
crocheting and combo brows yeah the
difference between the two
no so micro shading and combo brows is
the same it's just different names so
micro shading is a mix of microblading
and shading which is why they call it
combo brows
but same thing we have the same
technique as microblading but we usually
just do the microwaving in the front of
the brows and the outline
um the body of the brows and then we
shade in the inside
and we do that with an actual machine
just so it can create some more depth
and color
um it's usually recommended if clients
have like really oily skin or they have
really sparse areas in the hair so that
way it can look even more natural when
we add that depth and color with shading
so how long does this service last so
this one will last a little bit longer
just because it is done with machine as
well
so it'll last about two to three years
depending again if you have really oily
skin you might have to come in every
year
so if you look at this photo she has
enough brow hair for it to work with the
micro shading
um but her arch and tail is really
sparse so you can see now
the difference between her natural brow
versus the micro shading
and it'll still look really natural but
it's a little bit bolder than the micro
blading it'll give it like that soft
makeup look
with the full brow gorgeous and the
freckle tattoos i want to touch on this
because like i said earlier i see this
all over social media so how do you
work and why do people want this yeah
yeah so
freckles are i mean once they're healed
they do look like sun-kissed freckles
they're really cute
um what we do is we have a little
handheld tool and we same thing it's
just a small amount of pigment
and what we do is just lightly flick the
skin in the same area
to create some freckles and then
obviously we have different sizes
depending on
the size of the freckles that you want
it's one of my favorite services to do
because i just think it's fun and i've
always loved freckles but it is
definitely dependent on clients call
bina's beauty bar at 702-762-2000 she's
located right there on south
grand canyon drive we'll be right back